the mood is tense in New York City after
police there say a man with ties to Las
Vegas went on a rampage in a U-Haul
thank you for joining us at four I'm
Kirsten Joyce and I'm Brian Loftus seven
people one police officer were
hospitalized after they were struck by
the erratic driver happened in Brooklyn
the driver eventually apprehended the
investigation revealing ties right here
to Las Vegas including a lengthy
criminal history here in town Ryan
Matthew joins us live from Sunset and
Grand Canyon in Spring Valley near the
home he once lived in Ryan
yeah according to Witnesses and police
in New York this man swerved in and out
of sidewalks hitting multiple
pedestrians all in a nearly three mile
long Chase but before all of that the 62
year old man served prison time here in
Clark County and in court documents
mental health concerns are listed his
name Wang soar he's seen right here he
has since been arrested he's now in
custody after the incident in Brooklyn
it was about 7 30 Las Vegas time this
morning the 8 news now investigators
finding in Clark County court documents
that he stabbed his brother in 2015 and
had a quote unknown type of mental
health illness for which he takes
medication while awaiting that
sentencing he was charged with another
battery and served 16 months
concurrently for both never on parole
then November 2020 he stabbed a roommate
in the arm the judge there first finding
he was not competent to stand trial He
was ordered to serve a year in the Clark
County Detention Center for that most
recently he was cited for speeding up to
40 miles per hour over the speed limit
now we did stop at his last own
residents today no one ever answered the
door when we knocked on it and family
here still in the valley we've yet to
reach but when we spoke to the neighbors
of that household they say at least as
of recently they haven't seen him
reporting live here in Spring Valley
Ryan Matthey a news now